[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein richtig superschnelles
rezept als ich habe 20 minuten gebraucht
bei der vorbereitung noch schnell was
essen und bewegung und schon weiß fertig
und vor allem ist es so lecker und ihr
kennt das vielleicht noch gar nicht und
zwar heißen heißt diese süßigkeit rock
the words sohn ist der postbote aber das
training war okay alles klar doch noch
mal weiter
keywords morath weiß was das heißt
steinigeweg das ist wahrscheinlich an
über geht dann können wir dann genau an
rocky balboa steiniger weg und zwar weil
das ganze aussieht wieso eine steinige
straße und die sind wirklich super
lecker das ist peter quartiere mit
verschiedenen zutaten vermischt auf
einem blech gestrichen das ist ein
richtiger kraut feder der bereitet ein
blech zu und dann hat man wirklich was
wird ganz ganz viele menschen und vor
allem kann man sogar gut aufgewandt kühl
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten
die ich dafür verwende war doch ganz
kurz wie menschenbabys aus dem kraut
vieler ist als für die normalen menschen
mich kraus wieder einfach eine portion
wo man in der großen mengen viele
menschen machen kann ist hier normal in
schwarz rot und zwar achte klasse
hauptschule leisten eine definition geht
bestimmt in den toten aber ich zeige
mich jetzt mal die zutaten dafür
verwende ich 500 gramm zar peter kurer
türe 180 gramm brettl
hier habe ich noch erdnüsse die sollten
auf jeden fall gesessen sein
gefriergetrocknete himbeeren cranberries
und mini marshmallows ich habe jetzt
hier vorne einfach mal meine
lieblingszutaten aber ihr könnt
natürlich die zutaten einfach auch
variieren
ich finde immer ganz gut wenn auch
gesalzene zutaten dabei sind wir jetzt
die brezeln oder auch die erdnüsse und
dann noch ein paar fruchtige die
kuvertüre wird es gehackt und dann
geschmolzen und da muss eben temperiert
werden damit später kein grauer schleier
entsteht und sie eben auch schön glänzt
dafür wird jetzt die kuvertüre gehackt
oder auch fein gerieben und dann könnt
ihr sie zum beispiel über dem warmen
wasserbad erwärmen
zwei drittel davon dann hat sie etwa 50
grad und mit dem restlichen drittel kühl
tier an die kuvertüre wieder herunter
ich habe das ganze jetzt einfach hin der
kenwood gemacht und dort temperiert da
gibt es auch ein spezielles programm
geführt
sie muss dann so etwa 29 grad haben
und jetzt kann ich sie hier eingeben in
eine große schüssel
also ich könnte jetzt auch in der
kloschüssel lachen aber damit er was
machen sie mit der glas schüsseln mit
kommen einfach die ganzen zutaten da
rein also die brezel und die zurück ich
so ein bisschen oder auch nicht eine
kamera im ganzen reihen
[Musik]
dann die erbhöfe die gefriergetrockneten
himbeeren die machen es richtig lecker
fertig wer möchte kann zum beispiel auch
die cranberries zufügen und marshmallows
marshmallows findet man übrigens im
türkischen supermarkt auch mit rinder
gelatine aber es gibt auch schon
varianten glaube ich ohne gelatine jetzt
einfach alles ganz gut verrühren und am
anfang als ich das gesehen habe war das
muss doch bestimmt ganz süß schmecken
und ist gar nicht so mein fall aber ist
es wirklich super super lecker müsste
auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren alles
gut vermischen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt diese gesamte masse einfach
in der formel 1 ist im prinzip egal
welche auf jeden fall sollte er später
den schokoriegel natürlich auch wieder
rausbekommen
ich nehme jetzt einfach den bug rahmen
mit einer dauer back folie und so kommt
es dann nämlich gleich in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
und mit der gewählten form könnt ihr
dann auch die höhe der rockets bestimmen
jetzt wird einfach alles schön flach
gedrückt und ist schon jetzt sieht es
aus wie eine steinige straße und daher
kommt eben auch der name und sobald ich
das schön glatt gestrichen und flach
gedrückt hat kommt in den kühlschrank
und wir müssen nur noch warten bis die
masse fest ist nach dem glatt streichen
habe ich die masse noch mit
gefriergetrockneten himbeeren bestreut
jetzt kann sie aus der form herausgelöst
werden das geht am besten mit einem
messer debug folie natürlich vorher
wegziehen und dann einfach in
mundgerechte stücke schneiden
ok so ganz mundgerecht sind sie jetzt
nicht morath vielleicht für deinen mund
aber müssen wir werden okay
ja ich hab das rezept ich habe es von
meiner freundin und ich glaube ehrlich
okay aber sag mal ehrlich man ja aber
ich muss euch kurz was sagen also ich
habe es von meiner freundin iris und als
ich das bei ihr gesehen habe habe ich so
gedacht das ist bestimmt viel zu süß
aber dadurch dass man salzige zutaten
hat wie salz plätzen und erdnüsse
moralisches echt lecker ist viel zu süß
neben spaß und man muss es auf jeden
fall mit peter kolba tore machen weil
freue mich wird so süß dass auf jeden
fall diese kommen die zahl der koffer
türe die salzigen zutaten die süßen
beeren geschlecht lassen aber ich muss
etwas ehrliches sagen sagt nach zwei
drei stücken ersten zwei drei stück
nummer zwei ist aber ich finds auch
richtig cool denn red den werde ich
jetzt aufbewahren einfach cool im
kühlschrank zum beispiel oder im kühlen
keller wird auch gehen wenn er nicht so
viel platz im kühlschrank habt und ich
glaube nicht dass sie lange überleben
werden denn wir sind viel zu lecker also
einmal angefangen wahrscheinlich mal die
kalorien ausgerechnet ich glaube nicht
ein bisschen verrückt ist 100% verboten
aber ich glaube das geht sogar noch ist
gar nicht ich sag's dir erleben aber
schmeckt kommt motiv oder schlimmer ok
also viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]